dieu t'a créé pour que tu sois maire je
ne suis pas fait pour c'est dit alors
pourquoi as-tu fait elle accomplira la
volonté des dieux
pourquoi ne pas le suivre tout va nous
le reprocher
il faut que le peuple se soulève je ne
savais pas que nous étions des soldats
c'est ce qu'on ressent quand on ne fait
qu'un avec dieu on ne m'a jamais demandé
ce que je ressentais tué mon fils n'est
ce pas alors il faut de préparer à quoi
le perdre
c'est le prophète du diable le royaume
de dieu
acheter de faux
ce qui va arriver c'est dieu qui lui a
demandé
tu seras mon témoin
avec toi jusqu'à la fin
on ne parle plus jamais
en ce moment
je ne me tairais pas
je me ferai entendre
[Musique]